e
[Música]
o vídeo encerro aqui e começa aqui de
novo eu vou pegou fogo velho
o
filme mamãe Oi oi
tá eu vou arrumar aí a mãe tá eu vou
arrumar mãe
todo mundo conseguir travar morreu é
bonito que eu não quero mais merda
[Aplausos]
cirurgia
ai meu deus mamãe todo mundo preocupado
aqui achando que a senhora caiu aí
dentro todo mundo louco nessa casa não
tem é doido é doido é todo doido não tem
um certo é doido é doido no banheiro é
doido embaixo doido aqui que que esse
menino que tá
E aí
o
frio
olha o boi você mora no link a chegar
olha aí ó ó olha aí velho é isso que é
louco velho o velho não é meu vô pegou
fogo aqui velho flamejante de Dom
flamejante
caminhão já vou cara a minha avó minha
avó flamejante velho
para você já pagar aqui tá chegando a
guarda também no episódio anterior o
chuveiro não tava esquentando mãe a
gente [ __ ] como a gente vai tomar
banho agora que que aconteceu a minha
voz Sertão a água para tomar um banho
quente aí acabou que ela pegou fogo
velho
galera o Joselito animar olha não pegou
fogo não A
Barata de merda não tem vão aqui fazer
Vai tomar no cu tá bom entendi cara do
[ __ ]
O mãe o que que a gente vai comer hoje
hoje vai ter uma função de vegetais é
pelo reaproveitamento né coisa do dia de
sopa Josimar tomar ele vai
perder seguidores
imagem e o barrado sopa não sopa não
nossa
comida Arroz macarrão
pão e é que a vó vai comer a janta que
tem
tá bom
não dá para acreditar velho
como é que tá sempre jogando o
o
bairro Santa Branca Dá para arrumar dois
mesmo tempo que ele não é domingo né
e com perfil você não vem me mostra para
seus seguidores esse jogo é bem maneiro
eu vou comer um grupo velho
o
ifun grande na hora que eu tô conhecendo
ela tá aqui tu já já O Gabriel vai me
explicar direitinho que ele sabe tá em
[ __ ] do jogo Games pegue como ninguém
velho um grande aí galera Vanessa
boa tarde
resolvi trazer a caixa de ferramenta
porque eu pensei vai ter uma vaquinha de
mesa com as aqui é
isso aí ó
Ah tá todo tempo para câmera em que ano
na cara da pessoa e logo Josimar para
com isso
rapaz eu já tô só com Bíblia não parece
o menino do interior você fazer a
ladeira se vai tirar e vocês e Ray me
diz a temperatura pode trovoada é base
vai ser melhor é você postando um vídeo
vai ganhando
rebocando um vídeo de estudando e eu e a
mulher
viajando por aí galera entre que chegou
então não vai ter mais problema lá com a
tomar banho cara atrás aqui ai
eu vou tomar banho depois de 9 dias tudo
bem só tem dois dias que o banheiro
chuveiro quebrado mas é que o botão eu
só econômico ai ai ai
que susto hein
E aí
mano foi mal eu
eu tenho carinho queimar velho
saiu essa carta meu eu voltei é para
fora do corpo para que a poutra
E aí
e
eu vou voltar de novo Biel em tem sim
como fazer aqui o fabiel é que eu sabia
que tava jogando aqui ainda cara vai
continuar a apresentação do
o personagem sapatos e o botão
de pena pelo meu
22 O jogo é muito da hora eu tenho
música do ataque enviado da linhagem de
único que eu não tipo especial de sede
Inazuma agora tá que rápido como o vento
e poderosa eu tô muito vamos por aí é
dele é extremamente forte e habilidoso
Gabriel tá mudando que foi esse mãe mãe
o Gabriel tá virando homem mãe sabia que
tinha acontecido porque eu já fique que
espelho tu pediu nele lá no banheiro do
patologi i
Ah
não mano tô tirando onda não tinha legal
cara já gente tá o cheirando das
mulheres
a continuar vendas não é
e não mais sério sem brincadeira agora
muito irado quando você contar assim por
toda a empolgação que você tá dentro do
jogo mesmo dá vontade de acompanhar o
que que vai acontecer com ela tá quinta
ainda hein
e ele
a comer não tem como você me conquistou
muito bom não tem muitas pessoas que
gosta dele então quer dizer até que tem
muita vontade de viver ele botar outro
aqui e já fui a a conjunto estarão como
é que eu falei assim que achei
carismático assim brincalhão e até lá no
fofo com Jussara é o personagem mais
forte quando quente
e apagou mas com sua visão
E acredite
ele é bonitão né parece comigo eu me
vejo Nele até matá-lo
e
depois da noite tem muito a ver com você
quem tem um Carisma único digitei todos
os tipos de seguidores Celebrai ele tem
ar Attack game e ele conquistou milhões
de seguidores no sempre daqui eu vou
sair do seu canal do YouTube seu
conhecimento e
[Música]
eu
queria fazer uma pergunta para senhora é
e o que que é aqui ó eu pareço com ela
tá aqui tu
Ara Ketu para que já
vai o personagem a indo do jogo que o
Gabriel aí tá viciado game Tech agora tá
aqui Hilton eu não
bota essa merda e o
tu achas que vai tomar
e Gabriel
o quê
o
meu próprio grito
baixo vejam foi um pouquinho mais cedo
ou mais tarde a gente conversa vai dar
vi algum momento a energia volta dessa
casa direto
Esse é um eletricista o seu pêndulo é né
Ele é engraçado ele não só fala aí mano
não é um
o
[ __ ] [ __ ] crise crise da energia
aqui velho
é claro que tá o meu cabelo chá tomar
meu Deus do céu tenho eu só posso ter
Será que que aconteceu comigo eu nasci
né velho olha só você ver como é que eu
vou lá do tempo Mário faça o bagulho
postas as paradas do Gummy Hair para que
a hora que eu preciso acaba energia da
minha casa né que tu tá falando de
alguém aí velho sei lá é isso aí tempo
todo vai levar porrada em gostei e
aguarde o próximo episódio tem muita
água para rolar ainda tá família muito
louca é
[Música]